♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-George Washington didn't
actually cut down a cherry tree,
so he [bleep] lied to us.
What kind of psycho?
So his dad sees it,
cut down cherry tree,
goes to him.
Now we know, thanks to
the jackals, he never did it.
He says what happened here?
And George Washington said,
I cannot tell a lie.
I cut it down.
To what end?
[ Laughter ]
You know, we talk a lot about
how Donald Trump...
I think they've all been
[bleep] nuts.
[ Laughter ]
The Benjamin Franklin
key story as well.
Someone said
the Benjamin Franklin key story
is 1,000% fake.
And all I'd say to that is,
Oh, something can't be
1,000% fake.
[ Laughter ]
Did I do that, right?
I think I did that right.
I will say, very empowering.
Get why you guys do it.
It's pronounced
zoo-aa--luh-juhst,
not zoo-logist.
And just a question
for the zoologists.
When they told you that was
going to be the pronunciation,
none of you wanted
to step in?
[ Laughter ]
Now, why didn't you wanted
to say, "Alright,
but we're going to be
correcting people forever?"
Just give the people
what they want.
Make it zoo-logist.
Someone said,
oh, the problem is,
in order for it to be zoologist,
you'd need three O's in a row,
two for the zoo,
and then one for the ologist.
Great.
[ Laughter ]
Be the only -- be
an answer on Jeopardy!
Be the only word
with three O's in a row.
Guys.
[ Laughter ]
Fingerprints
are taken digitally now,
so if Donald Trump
has black ink on his fingers,
that means his Sharpie exploded.
And if it's blue ink,
he robbed a bank.
We said because
he got fingerprinted,
it was going to open up the cold
case file in New York City.
And I said we got -- there's
a break in the case for the
Westchester Strangler.
Bunch of people said
they didn't think Donald Trump
would be capable
of strangulation.
And they made a lot
of little hand jokes.
And that ain't us, guys.
We don't mess with that
2015 Donald Trump comedy.
We've all been through a lot.
We've grown up.
Been through a pandemic.
We left little hand jokes
on the other side.
I think, though,
he couldn't be the West Side --
Westchester, excuse me,
Strangler,
just because of a lack
of sticktoitiveness.
You know, based on every movie,
you've got to really want it.
And -- maybe a choker.
I think he'd be, you know,
I think he'd be like
halfway through the
strangulation
and he'd be like,
"Alright, I think you get it."
[ Laughter ]
Off you go.
I said he -- after he got
arraigned,
he took the FDR Highway.
A lot of you told me
it's the FDR Drive.
Do you guys not know
about the FDR Highway?
It's right next to me.
It goes so much faster.
You're still taking the drive?
Alright.
[ Laughter ]
Corrected myself,
it's not a slice of pizza.
Last week, I clarified
It's a sector of a pizza.
Not a triangle, it's a sector.
And someone said
it's actually a sector
of the radian of the pizza.
You want to use the
correct math terms, and I do
and I can't wait to tell Tony
down at the slice shop.
[ Laughter ]
All these signs
got to get changed, Tony.
[ Laughter ]
I said Medicis.
It is not pronounced that way.
I think the best way
to move forward
is I just stopped
talking about him.
I don't have a lot
to add about him.
A bunch of you tried to teach me
the right way to say it,
and I don't think
it's going to happen.
Oh, we talked about the straw
that broke the camel's back.
And then as Lindsey Graham,
I said,
Well, guess what?
I have one more straw.
That's not the problem
when a straw breaks a camel's
back that you ran out of straws.
It's that you don't need
another straw,
you need another
camel's back.
You can't get high off hemp.
Could of use that advice minutes
before completing
my first drug deal.
[ Laughter ]
That was an embarrassing night
back at the frat house,
trying to stuff
that thick sailor's rope
into the bong bowl.
[ Laughter ]
Keith Richards, we talked about
Keith Richards smoking, vaping
and noticing it was
a flavored vape.
Keith Richards would not say
cotton candy.
He would say candy floss.
Candy floss is why British
people have such bad teeth.
[ Laughter ]
Chicken can eat shrimp.
Shrimp can also eat chicken.
It takes forever.
[ Laughter ]
If you're a waiter
at a restaurant
and you have a table of shrimp
and they order the chicken,
you're not going to --
you're not going to turn
that table over.
They're going to be there
the whole night.
They're like,
"The chicken is good.
Can I -- can I suggest
the algae?
[ Laughter ]
I said -- we played a clip
and I said,
when we play this clip,
listen for the audible gasp.
And one of you said,
You don't need to say audible.
There's no such thing
as an inaudible gasp.
Is that right?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, we always talk about
how the rule is
don't look directly
at an eclipse.
Very helpful jackal pointed out
you're just not supposed
to ever look at the sun.
It's just on eclipse day
people forget.
[ Laughter ]
Which is true.
It's not like a non eclipse day
I walk outside, I'm like,
there she is.
[ Laughter ]
This is a note from a viewer.
It's the sort of stuff
I have to sort through
in my weekly endeavor to put
Corrections together.
Verbatim what they wrote.
"Your backdrop features
two rivets in the center beam,
stage right of your shoulder
and two rivets
stage right of that which serve
no structural purpose at all.
There are no other rivets
holding any part
of that backdrop together.
How's the rest of it
staying together, Seth?
How?"
[ Laughter ]
Well, that was [bleep] riveting.
[Laughter]
Hey...
we're posting a poll,
you know,
trying to figure out
which is the best
of our Emmy submissions.
We posted on Twitter,
and a lot of you said,
You know what? Why are you doing
it on Twitter?
A lot of people,
a lot of jackals
have stopped using Twitter,
and that's a very fair point.
We're on YouTube, and we're
going to try to post a poll
on our YouTube page.
Go to the community tab.
The poll is going to be there.
We hope it works.
And once again,
we're going to say
we still think
it's it's 66 or 69.
And, guys...
don't just pick 69 because,
you know.
[ Laughter ]
To quote a former first lady,
"Be best."
[ Laughter ]
Guys, I don't even know...
how we got on --
I don't even remember
how we got on hearse drivers,
but we did.
And it opened
a whole can of worms.
Incidentally, can of worms,
Hearse driver slang for coffins.
[ Laughter ]
We said coffins.
Many said caskets
are more common now.
Difference,
coffins taper at the bottom.
They conform with the body,
the human body,
and save you a little bit
of money on wood.
That's just the tip of the
iceberg of the hearse community,
hearse commentary this week.
It was pointed out to me
that, you know, hearse drivers
aren't actually in mourning.
It's just a job to them.
I agreed.
I said they punch in,
drop off the body
at the graveyard and punch out.
A bunch of you said
they should return the hearse
before punching out.
Obviously.
I assumed -- I didn't think
a guy would just drop,
like, punch out at the cemetery,
then his boss calls him,
it's like,
"Hey, Gary, where's the hearse?"
And he's like,
"Oh, I left it at
the graveyard."
He says, "Why did you leave it
at the graveyard?"
He's like, Oh, you're going to
need something
to get the body back."
"We don't want the body back."
I also said, you know,
they -- it's very important
for hearse drivers
not to get attached
to the cargo,
so much so they refer
to it as freight.
In order for it to be freight,
it has to be in bulk.
But I'm guessing there's a --
there's been a hearse driver
who's tried to double up,
save a trip.
Also, they don't call him
hearses anymore.
They call them coaches
or funeral coaches.
Man, I remember my high school
funeral coach.
[ Laughter ]
"You call that grieving?!
You look like you're
at a [bleep] cotillion ball!
[ Laughter ]
Am I supposed to believe
you missed this grandmother
or you [bleep] hate her guts?
You call that a veil,
Patterson?
[ Laughter ]
It's got bigger holes
than a tennis net.
I could see his whole face.
Wipe that smirk off it.
I'll knock you back down
to the JV funeral squad.
[ Laughter ]
You'll be flushing goldfish
back down toilets again."
[ Laughter ]
-That's.
Coach Mackenzie.
Rest in peace.
[ Laughter ]
Played a little, um...
Stevie Nicks.
It was, you guys,
some of you caught it.
It was a sound alike,
because when you use
an actual song,
it can't stay up
on YouTube forever,
which is the problem.
Some of you pointed out
episode 40 is missing.
It's because we we played
an Eminem song,
and I have no regrets.
But you can't keep it up
on YouTube.
If you use
an actual known song,
there are music
licensing issues.
That's why, like,
if you go on YouTube,
you can't watch, say,
Carpool Karaoke.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, so we played
"Edge of Seventeen,"
the Stevie Nicks sound alike.
And the first line of that song
is "just like
the white-winged dove."
And many of you admitted,
which I really appreciated,
that you would always
thought the lyric
was just like
the one-winged dove,
which is so dumb
that you just accepted that.
Like, a beautiful song
was about what?
A one-winged dove with just,
I guess, what?
Like, flying
in tight little circles.
[ Laughter ]
I don't think
a white-winged dove --
a one-winged dove
would be going
hoo, hoo, hoo!
[ Laughter ]
♪ Sounds like
a white-winged dog ♪
Like, she's singing
my [bleep] wing!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I intimated that pigeons
and doves are different.
That they belong
to the same family of birds.
Pigeons are --
they're the same family birds.
Pigeons are known
as rock doves.
A name they're given because
pigeons are dumb
as [bleep] rocks.
[ Laughter ]
Oh. I said, a flock of doves.
It's a bevy of doves.
A bevy of doves.
It's a flight of pigeons.
It's all very interesting.
You like knowing how to refer
to birds as groups, Shoemaker.
So a bevy of doves
sounds like this.
[ Doves cooing ]
A flight of pigeons
sounds like this.
[ Pigeons cooing ]
And a flock of seagulls
sounds like this.
-♪ And I ran,
I ran so far away ♪
-So bad news. You only got
30 days to watch this one.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
It's weird because I thought
a flock of seagulls
sounded like this.
-♪ Run away, turn away, run
away, turn away, run away ♪
-But that is a -- is
a beat of bronskis.
[ Laughter ]
Remember I showed you guys
this little fella last week?
I looked in the box,
and this was there.
And I don't know if it was
for something else,
but it was like that --
I hope they're not saying
that this looks like Wally.
[ Laughter ]
Come on.
Oh.
We got a two week hiatus,
everybody.
So just know that we're also
bitching about it here.
So see me in three weeks.